Transcription: Mylène François
Relecteur: eric vautier
D’après une étude récente,
un jeune sur deux est éco-anxieux.
Un jeune sur deux.
Moi, je suis éco-anxieuse.
C’est-à-dire que je suis angoissée
par le dérèglement climatique,
par l’avenir,
par la trajectoire que l’on suit,
et dans laquelle on avance
sans se poser de questions.
Je suis le genre de personne
qui fait des rêves la nuit
où la banquise et les glaciers fondent
et où le niveau des océans monte.
Je fais des rêves de submersion
où des villes entières sont emportées.
Et je rêve que je me tiens là,
impuissante.
Ça, pour l’instant,
ce ne sont que des rêves,
ou plutôt des cauchemars.
Mais c’est la réalité
que je vais vivre dans ma chair
si on ne prend pas
dès aujourd’hui et collectivement
des actions radicales
pour changer de trajectoire.
Et c’est la triste réalité que vivent déjà
des personnes pas si éloignées de nous.
J’en veux pour témoin cet été 2021,
meurtrier, marqué par les incendies,
les inondations,
et la première famine climatique au monde.
Je suis éco-anxieuse,
et pendant longtemps,
j’ai travaillé dans une multinationale.
Je menais
des politiques environnementales,
j’étais impliquée au niveau syndical,
et à toutes les couches de l’entreprise.
Et puis, un matin, je me suis réveillée.
Vraiment réveillée.
Je me suis regardée dans une glace et je
me suis dit : « Mais tu fais quoi là ? »
Ça faisait trois ans que je me démenais,
que je faisais mon maximum
pour que l’entreprise opère
de vrais changements
face au dérèglement climatique,
mais trois ans que cette même entreprise
continuait de couler du béton
pour faire des routes,
des aéroports et des bâtiments.
Trois ans pendant lesquels,
lorsque je demandais de réduire
l’empreinte environnementale du numérique,
on me suggérait d’imprimer
des stickers « Stop mail »
à coller sur tous les ordinateurs.
Je venais de m’apercevoir
que j’étais la caution verte,
la bonne conscience d’un système
qui nous mène à notre perte.
Alors, je suis partie.
D’abord, mon éco-anxiété se traduisait
en colère contre le système,
mais j’en ai fait mon carburant
pour me mobiliser tous les jours
et une magnifique joie.
C’est cette éco-anxiété qui fait
qui je suis aujourd’hui :
une activiste climat.
Je vais donc vous parler de ce mode
d’action qui a révolutionné ma vie,
de cette activité qui me transcende,
qui change mon rapport aux autres,
qui me donne de la force
et me fait sortir de mon impuissance.
Aujourd’hui, je vais vous parler
du passage à l’action,
de ce qu’on appelle l’activisme,
et de la force et du pouvoir du collectif.
De comment, ensemble,
on soulève des montagnes,
et comment les choses bougent.
De comment on se mobilise,
de comment on s’oppose à un système
qui arrive à bout de souffle,
et comment on construit l’avenir.
L’activisme, c’est un gros mot
pour certains,
un rêve pour d’autres.
Et pour quelques jeunes et
moins jeunes, comme moi, une réalité.
Et grâce à ce levier puissant
qui permet de faire pression sur ceux
qui nous gouvernent et les entreprises,
on remporte des victoires.
Je peux revenir sur le fait que,
en partie grâce à une action
de désobéissance civile,
un projet d’extension d’aéroport
a été abandonné.
Je peux également vous dire que,
grâce à des mobilisations constantes
et des interpellations publiques,
l’une des plus grosses banques françaises
a arrêté ses investissements
dans les énergies fossiles.
Je peux également vous affirmer que grâce
à la mobilisation de millions de citoyens,
le gouvernement français
a été traduit en justice,
condamné pour son inaction climatique
et forcé de réparer le préjudice subi.
Alors, peut-être que tout ça
est encore un peu obscur.
C’est quoi, l’activisme ?
En vrai, comme je pense
toutes les personnes ici présentes,
le matin, je me lève.
Je me lève et ensuite je travaille,
je travaille et j’agis
toute la journée,
et souvent jusqu’à 21h-21h30
qui est l’heure à laquelle
finit ma dernière réunion.
Il y a un côté assez normal
dans ce que je fais,
mais aussi très construit,
car l’activisme, c’est très sérieux.
Je construis donc des plans de
communication pour des actions à venir.
Je participe à des réunions de stratégie
où l’on va prioriser
nos axes de travail
pour les prochains mois.
J’appelle des bénévoles,
des nouvelles personnes,
et je les accueille dans le mouvement.
Je travaille aussi les week-ends.
Et j'adore ça.
Ça, c'est mon quotidien.
Après, il y a des journées
un peu plus spéciales.
Je participe à
des formes d’action différentes,
désobéissantes ou non,
plus ou moins risquées.
Néanmoins, toujours non-violentes.
Pour ce type d’action,
seule une poignée d’activistes
est au courant
des tenants et aboutissants,
et sait exactement ce qui va se passer.
Ils et elles préparent ça pendant des
semaines avec joie et détermination.
Et puis, il y a une dizaine, une centaine
de personnes qui gravitent autour,
qui savent qu’il va se passer un truc,
qui ont accepté de participer,
mais qui ne savent pas
encore trop ce que c’est.
Et ça, c'est moi.
Vous voyez un peu les films d’espionnage ?
Trois semaines plus tôt,
je discutais avec quelqu’un.
Il était 21 heures, il faisait nuit
et on rentrait chez nous.
Cette personne m'a demandé si j'étais
disponible dans les semaines à venir
parce qu'une action confidentielle
se préparait.
Et j'ai dit oui.
Les 3 semaines précédant l’action, j’ai
reçu des bribes d’infos au fil de l’eau :
une date écrite sur un papier,
le rôle que j’occuperais.
Par messagerie cryptée,
je reçois des instructions
sur la façon dont je devrais m’habiller
et où est ce que je dois
me rendre et à quelle heure.
Donc là,
ça fait trois semaines que je sais
que je vais me lever à 5 heures,
que je vais aller à l’autre bout de Paris,
et je dois vous avouer que
tout ça est super excitant.
Parce qu’on sera ensemble,
et que chacun d’entre nous
sait pourquoi il le fait.
Ce matin-là, donc, debout à 5 heures.
J’ai en fait rejoint
l’équipe communication,
car je n’ai pas pu m’introduire dans
le lieu que l’on occupait comme prévu.
Pendant toute la matinée,
j’ai diffusé les images des activistes
présents sur le terrain.
Sur les réseaux sociaux,
par mail, auprès des journalistes.
Ce matin-là, on a fait un travail
de communication incroyable,
et on a parlé de nous
jusqu’aux États-Unis.
De ces activistes
ayant interrompu le discours
d'un ministre en plein sommet
sur la finance.
Ce matin-là, on a fait retentir
littéralement les alarmes
de l’urgence climatique
dans l’une des plus célèbres
salles parisiennes.
C'était le 26 octobre dernier.
Pour ce type d’action,
on est préparés toute l’année,
on se forme aux techniques de blocage,
à l’action non-violente,
à quoi dire et ne pas dire
en cas de garde à vue.
On se forme à
la communication non-violente,
à être « contact police »,
ou encore « peacekeeper ».
S’il nous arrive quelque chose
lors d’une action,
des activistes se chargent
de nous envoyer un avocat,
nous attendent à la sortie
du poste de police,
et nous ramènent chez nous.
C’est ça, la puissance du collectif.
Bon, là, ça fait deux minutes que
je vous parle de désobéissance civile,
et d’actions coup de poing,
mais on ne fait pas que ça
et je ne fais pas que ça.
On dit souvent dans le mouvement
qu’on a deux jambes
et que l’une ne peut aller sans l’autre.
Cette première jambe, d’opposition,
est cruciale pour
interpeller l’opinion publique,
dénoncer les responsables
du dérèglement climatique,
et gagner peu à peu
la bataille culturelle.
Et notre deuxième jambe, c’est la jambe
de la proposition d’alternatives.
Et oui, dans le mouvement climat,
je ne fais pas que m'opposer.
Je construis, je construis
le monde de demain.
Le monde dans lequel je veux vivre.
Et je le construis au quotidien
à travers tous les projets
dans lesquels je m’engage.
Les solutions pour lutter efficacement
contre le dérèglement climatique
existent déjà,
et par mes engagements,
je contribue à rendre
ces solutions alternatives visibles,
accessibles et désirables.
Cette année, par exemple,
j’ai participé à l’inauguration
de la première maison
de l’écologie populaire en France,
implantée en plein cœur
d’un quartier populaire en Île-de-France.
Le principe de l'écologie
populaire est simple.
On veut une écologie
par et pour les citoyens.
Une écologie qui part du peuple
et qui parle des personnes
qui sont les premières concernées
et les premières victimes
du dérèglement climatique
et des injustices qui y sont liées.
Une écologie qui part
des catégories de la population
à qui on nie la légitimité
de se revendiquer des luttes écologistes.
On ne veut pas
d’une écologie des puissants,
d’une écologie descendante,
celle des petits gestes individuels
qui culpabilisent les individus
quand les multinationales
continuent de polluer.
Concrètement, on a passé des soirées
entières à faire du porte-à-porte,
à tracter, à coller des affiches
dans les rues
pour que les habitants entendent
parler de ce nouveau lieu
et qu’ils viennent à notre rencontre.
Assez rapidement avec eux, on a identifié
qu’un énorme problème existait
à quelques mètres de là.
Un échangeur autoroutier
qui brasse des centaines
de milliers de voitures par jour,
qui génère une énorme pollution
atmosphérique et sonore.
Je me rappelle ce père venu
témoigner avec son fils de six ans
et qui nous avoue qu’il doit
l’emmener faire du vélo plus loin,
car l’air autour d’eux est trop pollué.
Il est irrespirable.
Son fils est asthmatique
et il ne peut pas faire de vélo
sur leur lieu d'habitation.
C’est ça, la réalité.
On a organisé des concertations avec les
élus locaux pour qu’eux et les habitants
puissent discuter des solutions
à apporter à cette pollution,
ensemble.
Et ça, c'est une victoire.
Grâce à ce lieu, des centaines de
personnes vont pouvoir s’organiser
et construire un monde plus juste,
un monde qui leur ressemble,
un monde où justice écologique
et justice sociale
ne peuvent se passer l’une de l’autre.
Voilà, je vous ai livré une infime
partie de mon quotidien,
une infime partie de ma vie d’activiste.
Cette éco-anxiété qui m’habite toujours
et avec laquelle je vis,
j’en ai fait ma plus grande force.
C’est celle qui me pousse
chaque jour à agir pour le mieux,
celle qui me fait faire des choses que
je n’imaginais même pas faisables,
celle qui m’a fait rencontrer
un collectif si puissant
que demain, je les suivrai
au bout du monde.
En voilier, hein, pas en avion.
J’ai transformé cette éco-anxiété,
initialement paralysante
parce que j’étais seule,
en une réelle force pour
passer à l’action collectivement.
Et vous ?
Quelle est la force qui vous
pousserait à l’action ?
(Applaudissements)